- The intention for today's
hour is really just to relax
just to unwind, not a lot of
information coming at you,
just embodied practices.
And I know that a lot of you
probably have commitments
at home right now, maybe kids coming in.
And so really just do what you can
and take those breaks as needed
and really there's no pressure to do this
in any certain way.
So we're just gonna start with
something that helps us relax
and that's stretching and
a little bit of massage.
So Jeremy, if you wouldn't
mind, we're gonna just have
some background music while we do this.
And wherever you are, if
you're seated at a chair
or I'm sitting on the floor right now
'cause that helps me relax a little more
but wherever you are,
if you're comfortable
you can just close your
eyes just to shut off
some stimuli that's unneeded right now.
It might be nighttime or
evening where you are,
so it might be cooler to
just take a moment to notice
the temperature and the
environment around you.
And then just take a moment
to notice the feeling
of your body on the chair,
the surface that you're on,
and notice where your hands are resting,
maybe notice if you're leaning
forward or leaning back,
or if there's any adjustment
that you'd like to make.
So there's more ease in your body.
And we're gonna set the
intention of letting go of time
and that sounds like a giant task,
but we'll see if we can touch
into this sense of timelessness
as if we had all the time in the world
to let go and unwind.
Just take a moment to
connect with your breath
breathing in through your nose
(inhales)
and then breathing out a little slower
through your nose or mouth,
just letting our nervous
systems start to unwind
and then just let your
breath find its own natural
easy rhythm, letting go of any effort
and then just notice any
sensations in your body.
So you might be hungry, you might be full,
you might notice your eyes are fluttering
and just as we notice these sensations
we don't have to try and change
them or make them different
but we can just kind of
greet them with curiosity
and acceptance, and that this
is how things are right now
and that's okay.
If you happen to notice pain
it might be difficult to
stay with that sensation
so you can just touch
into any sensation of pain
and then find a place in
your body where there's ease.
And sometimes we really
have to search for ease
maybe it's at the tip of our big toe
or one of our thumbs,
but somewhere in the body
usually there's a contact with ease.
So just allowing us to be
as we are in this moment,
less than perfect, just as we are.
And we're just going to add in
a little bit of movement here
just to stretch our body gently
and if any of these
movements don't work for you
you can just stay resting
and whatever position is comfortable.
So if you'd like to open your
eyes to see these stretches
you can, or you can keep your eyes closed
and just follow my verbal instructions.
So go ahead and anchor your
hand to a spot next to you
maybe you're holding onto a chair
or your fingertips are
resting on a couch or a desk
and then we're gonna lift our left arm up,
lift our left fingertips toward the sky
and just feel that length all the way down
from your fingertips to your hip.
And then we're just gonna
slowly reach over to our right
you can look down that
is nice on your neck
or you can look up and I'm
just keeping my eyes closed
just to stay embodied, just to stay with
the pleasant sensations of stretch
and loosening up the muscles.
Take a deep breath here
feeling your lungs expand
and a deep breath out,
and then reaching back up to the center
and then just letting
that left arm float down
and just pause to notice
different sensations
between the side we stretched
and the one we haven't stretched.
*Subtle tingling or heat
maybe more space in your
diaphragm to breathe.
And then we'll go to the other side
so just lifting that right
arm up toward the sky
reaching the fingertips up,
anchoring your left hand
then reach up and over toward your left,
feeling that stretch from
your right hip all the way
through to your right fingertips
and again, you can look
down, you can look up
and just take a few deep breaths
feeling your lungs expand.
And then on your next in
breath just reaching back up
and as you exhale slowly letting
that right arm drift down
again, just pausing here
noticing if you feel a little
different than when we started
maybe you can feel the nervous
systems start to unwind.
And if not, that's okay too,
sometimes our nervous system
kind of holds on tight
to what's going on or
what kind of day we had.
So that's okay too.
And then you can open your
eyes and just follow along
we're just going to do a few movements
to give ourselves some love,
give our muscles some love.
So just go ahead, if
it's comfortable for you
and you don't have any injuries
just go ahead and squeeze,
gentle squeeze here, right
in your shoulder blades.
This is where we hold a lot of tension
and then down the arm all
the way down to your forearm
and give a little squeezed
her hand and your fingers,
and let's just do that one
more time going back up,
squeezing and then again, pause,
just to notice the difference
between the side we squeezed
and the side we haven't yet.
A head, it's all about awareness, right?
We're just bringing awareness
to ease so we can identify it.
And then let's go to the other side
so just giving it a nice
squeeze to that shoulder blade
anywhere you feel tight
you can stay in that area
if you'd like and then you
can just work your way down
the arm, giving a squeeze to
the shoulder and the forearm
all the way down to your hand.
Maybe just look down at
your hand and your fingers
thinking about all the
things that they do,
they type, and they hug,
cook dinner, wash dishes
just giving love.
And then again, just pausing and seeing
if you can really feel
into the sensations,
maybe tingling, maybe lightness,
maybe some ease emerged
then we're gonna do one last movement.
So we're gonna make fists
with our hands like this,
you can tuck the thumbs
and do your fingers
and just hold the squeeze
for a few moments.
Noticing what happens in
the mind is we tense up
this is kind of representative
of how we sometimes
hold on to things or
resist what's happening
and then take a deep breath
in through your nose.
(inhales)
And as you breathe out,
just release the hands
opening the palms and
this hand gesture kind of
represents letting go or accepting,
or being open and curious,
notice how different that is.
And then the last movement we'll do
if you wanna open your
eyes to look is just
imagine you're kind of hugging a tree
and relax the shoulders down.
We don't want them to
be up toward your ears.
And imagine this gesture,
this posture is like
we're holding whatever we
encounter in this next 40 minutes
together with kindness,
whether someone interrupts our
session or we don't feel it,
we don't feel what we think
we're supposed to be feeling.
See if we can hold all of that
with kindness and compassion.
And then we can rest our hands
back down, opening our eyes.
So hopefully the nervous
system has started to enter
what we call the rest and
digest mode of operating, right?
Our parasympathetic nervous system.
The next few activities we're
gonna do are all about that.
All about activating our
parasympathetic nervous system
which is the opposite of our
sympathetic nervous system
which is our, what we call
fight or flight, right?
When we're stressed or we're
trying to get things done
or we're rushed, we wanna
move into the other way,
the opposite of that.
So I have a little exercise,
which is about thinking about teachers
that you've had in your life.
And these don't have to be
teachers you've had at school
but any kind of teacher that's
left an impression on you,
someone that has taught you
something or connected with you
someone with whom you felt really seen.
And I want you just to reflect on that
and maybe a few people
could share what comes up
when you think about that.
And as you're thinking,
as you're processing,
I'll just share a person I thought of.
She was my 11th grade science teacher
and I was really disenchanted with school,
at the time, I felt like I
wasn't able to really focus on
what I wanted to focus on,
which was neuroscience and psychology.
And she happened to go to UCLA
which at the time was my dream school
and she gave me a textbook from one
of her neuroscience
classes that she still had
and she told me that at
any time I could go sit
in *on classes at UCLA.
And I was so appreciative of
that because first of all,
she took my interests seriously,
she gave me a book that was special to her
and she let me know that I
could pursue my interests
and I didn't have to wait for it,
I could go sit in on a
lecture and be part of it
even though I hadn't
graduated high school yet.
So that was a teacher
that I'll never forget,
I'll remember her for the rest of my life.
So is there anyone who'd like to share
just a story of a teacher
you can share verbally,
I would love to hear your voices,
and I totally understand too,
if you you're not able to share verbally
'cause of what's going on at home.
But yeah, who's a teacher
in your life that you've had
maybe it's even a teacher
who inspired you to go
into this profession and yeah-
- [Jeremy] We're getting a
number of great responses
in the question section, which is awesome.
Carrie says her ninth to
12th grade music teacher
was totally present and authentic,
such an encouragement to all students.
And Katie says, fifth
grade teacher that I worked
with when I was a para,
I still think about him
and my classroom plans.
And then just to get a couple
of folks to share live,
I see some folks have raised their hands
so I'm gonna actually
unmute crystal Davis here.
So crystal, if you like,
you are now live with Sam.
- Hi crystal.
- Sometimes it can take a little while
for the audio to kick it.
Crystal, feel free to share,
I'm also gonna go over to Theresa here.
Theresa, if you're there,
feel free to share.
- [Crystal] Okay, they said I was muted,
can you hear me now?
- Yeah, we can hear you-
- Pretty great, yeah.
- [Crystal] Okay, awesome.
So for me, it's my fifth grade teacher,
her name was Gail Lidy,
I remember her like it was yesterday.
I had a very challenging childhood,
I'll just leave it at that
to make it comfortable for everyone
but she showed me that she loved me
even though I felt so uncomfortable.
And the biggest thing of all is that
I was actually able to meet her
after I finally got my
degree six years ago
and I did my student teaching
and she told me how
proud of me that she was.
And so I got a chance to
have that last conversation
with her before she passed away,
so just very super precious.
That's my share.
- That's amazing.
Thank you for sharing that
and I heard that the word
love really resonated with me.
Like you know when you're loved,
you know when you're cherished by someone,
even if it is a teacher,
that kind of connection
can translate or transcend to love
and that's why we're here,
I would say that's why
we're here on earth.
You know, we're here to
connect, we're here to love.
So it's an amazing connection you had
and so great that you
were able to meet with her
and let her know what
impact she had on you
because when we're kids
and my husband just told
me this too, he's like
we never get thank yous.
You know, the only thing he's that come
or when maybe when the students are older
and they realize, you
know, how important and
what sacrifices teachers made
and what effort they brought
forth to the classroom.
So, yeah and I'm sure
it meant a lot to her.
- Thank you so much Crystal
for that amazing share.
Let's go over to Theresa.
Theresa, I'm gonna unmute your line,
are you still there?
- [Theresa] Yes.
So I had a college professor in Algebra
that was a very difficult class.
It was my third algebra class
trying to take just to get
through so I could even take
a college Algebra course
was feeling very overwhelmed
and quite frankly
very stupid when it came to Algebra.
And he told me that even
if you don't get it one way
and showed me that if
you don't get it one way
there's always another
way to solve a problem
which is something that I've taken,
not just when it comes to math
but I've taken it into life as well.
That there's multiple
ways to solve our problems
and don't just stick
with that one message.
That's something that I brought
into my teaching as well
because I do the same
thing with my students now,
if they can't get it one way
then let's look at it a different way.
And it's been very successful
and has been a good thing for me to learn.
So I'm very thankful to Mr. Cherry,
who was an algebra teacher in college.
- Wow, that's a beautiful story
and the fact that he
was able to connect it
or you are connecting it to life
just that when we hit a
roadblock we have this capacity
to come up with creative solutions
or ways of looking at problems differently
and not just by ourselves,
but even asking for help
and being able to ask our teachers
to help us look at something
a new way, that's beautiful.
- Thank you so much.
- [Theresa] Thank you.
- So I would love for us to,
you might not know this practice
but it's called loving
kindness meditation,
and for the skeptics out there,
it can sound kind of wooey
because we're sending kind
wishes to someone else.
And it's not that we're in any kind
of delusional state that
we think we can send wishes
and they'll somehow be received,
we're doing it for ourselves.
There's been a lot of research
on this form of meditation
and the research has shown
that it connects us to,
well it has a lot of health benefits,
reduces inflammation, increases
and boosts our immune system.
But it also puts us in touch
with the neurocircuitry
that makes us wanna connect,
that helps us attune to each other
and helps us to be present
for another human being
and to be present for ourselves.
So it's really a selfish exercise
even though we're doing something
that sounds really benevolent for others
but it also makes you want,
sometimes it stimulates this desire
to reach out to the person or to write
a letter of thank you or to really just
be with them in a deeper way.
So we don't know exactly
what it's gonna do
but we go into it knowing it
will be in some way beneficial.
So I would love for us
to send some kind wishes
to the teachers that you thought of,
the teacher that came to mind
and I'll lead you through.
It's a very brief practice,
I'll lead you through it.
And just keep this person in mind
and keep the feeling alive in you,
the feeling of connection of being seen of
that freedom that you had when you
from your algebra
teacher, when you learned
that you could look at
something a different way
or that there were
multiple ways of solving it
how that kind of opened
it, like on tied the knot
that you may have felt when
you didn't get something.
So just keeping that feeling alive
and we can close our eyes,
if we're comfortable, you
can always rest your eyes
on a spot in front of you,
if you don't like to close your eyes.
And let's just bring that teacher to mind.
You can imagine that they're
in front of you or next to you,
maybe recall what they
look like, their demeanor
and just recall the moment of connection
that you had with this teacher.
And if no teacher came to
mind, you can just think
of someone you like or
love, someone in your life.
And if you'd like, you can
put a hand on your heart
but you definitely don't have to.
And I'm just gonna say some
words of kindness out loud
and just imagine that you're
sending this kindness,
you're genuinely wishing for
this person to feel this way.
May you be happy,
may you know you're appreciated,
may you be free from
pain, may you be healthy.
I'm just taking a breath to
reconnect to that feeling
of appreciation you have for this person.
May you be happy,
may you be safe,
may you be healthy and at ease.
(sighing)
And while we're here
just bringing to mind your own efforts
you can place your hand
down if it's getting tired.
But bringing to mind your efforts to show
up when you don't feel like it sometimes,
your efforts to be on time,
to be present your genuine
desire to show care
and concern for your
students, for your family
all of that effort and goodness
that you show to the world.
And if exceptions come up,
if you start thinking about,
well not always like
that, that's okay too.
Just notice what the mind does,
what the mind shows you greet it with,
remember that holding with
compassion and kindness
and we're just gonna send
some kind wishes to ourselves.
We're gonna use the word you,
just so we have that little bit of space
where our loving kind self
wishing it to our vulnerable,
maybe sometimes hesitant self.
So may you be happy, may you be safe,
may you be free from pain,
may you have ease.
(inhales) Taking a deep
breath in (exhales)
and out just to reconnect
with your efforts
and your goodness.
May you be happy, may you be safe,
may you know you're appreciated,
I may you feel at ease.
I'm just staying with the feeling of ease
that maybe has bubbled
up from this exercise,
we're holding whatever's here, skepticism.
May be you feeling of
difficulty or hesitation,
holding that with kindness,
not resisting it (sighs).
And when you feel ready,
you can open your eyes
and I just wanna open it up
again to the group to see
if anyone would like to share
what that was like for you.
Often, when we do this
loving kindness practice
for the first time, it can be,
we have what we call the
inner heckler, right?
We have this voice inner
voice kind of heckling us
and saying, what are you doing?
What is this?
But maybe you've tried it before,
maybe it just felt really natural to you.
So yeah, just feel free to jump in
and share what that
experience was like for you.
And again, we can do
it verbally or in chat.
I love hearing your voices,
that's my preference,
but whatever you can do
- [Jeremy] Christy says,
I'm always surprised of this
exercise can bring me to tears.
And Abby said, it made me wanna
call my guiding teacher and say, thanks.
And then I know there were a couple
of folks who'd wanna share online,
so I'm gonna go with Carol first.
So Carol, I've got open up your line,
if you wanna unmute yourself,
feel free to say hi to Sam.
- [Carol] Hello, can you hear me?
- Yeah, hi Carol.
- [Carol] Hi, for me,
I tell my students to do these things
and I don't always tell myself to.
And so to hear you, as
the teacher telling me
as the student to just send myself love,
it's that kind of switch that I think
teachers need more often.
So thank you.
- You're welcome, it's so true.
We get in the habit
of wanting to give advice, give tools
and then we're we forget to
do it for ourselves, right?
And we need teachers, right?
Just like we never
stopped needing teachers
and helpers as we get older.
- [Jeremy] And let's go next
to Elizabeth and Elizabeth
feel free to share your story with Sam.
- [Elizabeth] Sure, hi.
I always think it's awesome because
I have so many people I wanna thank
and I'm grateful for and appreciate,
but I can't remember your name
but you said it brings you to tears.
And that's what always
surprises me when I do stuff
like this, you'd come
in and like, it happens
and mine is, my brother
passed away at age 48,
a couple of years ago.
And we had a teacher we
both had in sixth grade
and she ended up moving
across the street from my mom.
And 15 years later, she had a picture
that my brother had given
her like a school picture.
And she told the story.
She said, he asked, well
do you want a school picture of me?
And she said, well, of course I do.
And so the next day he
came in with an eight by 10
and this is like in
the mid early eighties.
So she kept it and had it when she moved
in across the street from
my mom, like 15 years later.
And so it just was a pretty
amazing story that she
was able to tell us, you
know, at my brother's funeral.
And like she made a difference then
and continue to, you know.
- Wow, what a special woman.
Thank you for sharing that.
- [Jeremy] And Sam, do we
have time for one more share?
- Yes, we do.
- [Jeremy] Let's go over to
the Jamie (mumbles) actually.
So Jamie, I'm gonna unmute your line,
feel free to open it up yourself.
Hi, Jamie.
It looks like you might have
a little trouble with Jamie.
- Oh, okay.
- [Jeremy] Let me try with Jennifer here.
Hold on one second.
Jennifer, are you there?
Hi, Jennifer, how are you?
- [Jennifer] I'm good, how are you?
- Great, thank you so much for joining?
- [Jennifer] Yeah, again like everyone
I'm echoing just the sentiments of tears
and I was surprised
with how my other senses really connected
to when I was thinking about
my fourth grade teacher,
going back to that, I could
just like it was in the classroom
and I could hear his
laugh and see his smile
and it just felt so good.
And I made the connection that,
what made him so special,
he was always a hundred percent present
with us as his students.
And that gift of being
present is not forgotten.
- Yeah, wow, that's incredible.
The presence it's love, you know
it's the ultimate show of care
when you're present and it's hard,
it gets harder to develop in these times.
So when we need this time
to stop and just reflect
and I think we need people
to bring us into it,
we need all the tools we can get
to pull us in to this time,
to connect with each other,
to commune, to share stories.
So it's so precious and
when we do it, I don't know.
It sounds like a lot of
you are expressing this too
but when we do it, we
remember how good it is,
how good it feels and we wanna do it again
and again and again.
So yeah, it's just
rediscovering the importance
of community and connection, lovely.
I wanna take us into our next exercise
which is all about all awe, A-W-E.
I feel like we don't
use that word very often
because these moments of awe
for most of us happen infrequently.
A moment of awe to me
and how it's been defined
by the research is these
moments that leave you
or inspire this feeling of surprise
and you kind of feel small
because the thing feels
so big in a good way.
You feels you feel expansive,
you feel inspired, you feel,
you're completely absorbed in that moment,
you're not thinking about anything else
because the thing you're
witnessing is so beautiful
or so touching or so magnificent, right?
So these are moments
of awe and reflecting,
there's a lot of research, and I can share
with you the research
literature that the authors
there's a woman actually in Canada
who does this and these
amazing workshops on awe
but she's found in the research that awe
is really good for our mental health,
it stimulates our vagus nerve which again
activates our parasympathetic
nervous system
and helps us to actually feel
like we're suspended in time.
We lose track of time,
we're in this flow state,
so it's really good for us.
So I wanna introduce you to this activity
so that you can put yourself
in that state of awe
and then hopefully find a lot
of extraordinary moments
in the ordinariness
of life, of day-to-day life.
So what I'm gonna have you do is
and you can do this again
with your eyes open or closed.
I like to shut my eyes just to close out
all the visual stimuli
but we're going to think
of a moment of awe that we've had.
So think of a moment
when you were surprised
and suspended for a moment
in this feeling of amazement,
this feeling of connection,
maybe it was a connection
with a person or a moment of
witnessing a child being born
or seeing a wedding or someone's,
some experience where
you felt really present
and in awe of the beauty.
I'm gonna give you a few moments
in silence just to allow this memory
to bubble up without
pushing it or rushing it.
And as a moment comes to
mind, see if you can expand it
by noticing the details,
the sensory details.
So if there were people involved,
remembering what people were there
maybe even as you take a deep breath
you can remember the smell,
the sense in the air.
Maybe you can remember the sounds,
maybe you remember the
temperature, if it was a hot day
or a cold day, neutral.
And then remember what you
saw the colors, the shapes,
the facial expressions, the movements.
Then we're gonna connect with a movement
that represents this moment of awe.
So maybe it's your arms
open, or if you were
holding something, you might
put your arms in that position.
So just find a movement
in your body right now
or a gesture that represents
this moment of awe.
And just hold that movement or posture
for few breaths, helping
you connect to that feeling
to let it sock in (sighs).
Maybe you notice the thoughts that you had
at the time or the emotions
and you can place your hands back down
and just let that feeling simmer
for just a few more moments.
Then when you're ready, you can
if your eyes are closed,
you can open your eyes
coming back to the space
that we have together.
And I wanted to share
when I did this exercise
for the first time, what
moment of awe came to mind?
And I think Jeremy has a
photograph to pull up to show you.
It was, when I was 15
I went to Europe for the first time
and I saw the Coliseum, oh
that's a beautiful picture.
Yeah and I looked at it
and I heard the tour guide starting
to talk about the history and
some major points they
were making stuck out
like how old it was and the events
that used to take place inside.
But what got me was how old it was just,
how it withstood all this time passing
and all these different events in history
and it just stood there and it remained.
And my gesture was this,
you can't see my hands in the shot
but like, wow, Kind of pushed back by it
by how huge it was and how beautiful.
And I also just felt so lucky to be there,
I felt so lucky to
witness this living piece
of history that I had learned
about and in a textbook
and now I got to see it.
So that was my moment of awe
and I just, I really
did lose track of time,
I think I was there for hours
but it felt like only minutes went by.
So I would love to hear from you again
just what was your moment of
awe, what came up for you?
What sensory details did you recall?
And what did it feel like to just stay in
that feeling of awe?
There's a lot of research
showing that it takes 30 seconds
to a minute for a positive
emotion to really register
in our system for us to
kind of what they say
or what they call hard-wiring happiness so
that our default state becomes more likely
to look for the good, to look
for what we're grateful for,
to recall these moments of awe.
It becomes more of a habit over time,
if we really let it simmer
and stay with us for
longer periods of time.
So even talking about it
and listening to each other is helping us
to really develop that
hard wiring for the good
looking for the good, so
we can be fully present
with each other as we're
listening to these stories of awe.
And if you'd like, you
can share your gesture
and I can try to replicate it
and we can all do it together
so that we're mirroring each other
and really maybe even touching deeply
into empathizing with your experience.
So who would like to share?
- [Jeremy] We heard a number of great ones
in the question section, Sam needs to talk
about sunset on the rim
of the Grand Canyon.
Jackline talked about
the first time I was out
on the ocean without being
able to see the shore.
You met said the moment of owe
that really struck her
when she was presented
with her daughter for the first time
and she looked in her daughter's eyes
and has had a connection with her,
this lasted all the way into adulthood.
- It's an incredible
moment, I'm not a parent yet
but I imagine that moment
of, I mean overwhelming awe
when your child is placed in your arms.
And sometimes we'll do
these exercises with parents
and kids and have them
look into each other's eyes
and talk about the color of their eyes.
Like I noticed you have a little ring
around your eye and it's
light brown or whatever it is
but for me witnessing
those moments of connection
and seeing parents just
their whole face light up
as their child, children
are looking into their eyes
is for me, that's a moment of awe
that I happily get to
relive a lot of the time.
So yeah, just thank you for sharing that.
Let's invite some folks that join live.
Let's start with Michelle.
So Michelle, I'm gonna unmute your line,
feel free to do the same on your side.
Michelle, are you there?
- [Michelle] Yes, I am.
- Hi Michelle.
- [Michelle] Hi, this is amazing.
The first time I held each of my children
and it washed over me the enormity of
how my life would change after that
life as I had known, it
would never be the same
and in ways I couldn't
even at that time imagine,
so that, that was awesome (laughs).
- Beautiful, I got chills
all through my head
and back as you were describing that.
- [Michelle] Took my breath away.
- That's beautiful.
Was there a movement that came to mind?
Was it like holding?
- [Michelle] Yes, it was as
I cradled them in my arms
and looked down at their little faces.
And that was so many years
ago they're adults now,
but I can cherish that moment once again,
so I appreciate this.
I hadn't thought about
that in many, many years,
so thank you for that.
- Yeah, you're so welcome,
thank you for sharing.
Sometimes I look into, I work
with children quite a bit
and I look into their eyes
as if I was their parent.
Like I try to connect with
them with that kind of love
and unconditional positive regard,
if you wanna use therapy terms
but that feeling of connection.
And we can kind of do that
with other people, even
strangers, we can look
at them through the eyes of
a mother or a sister friend
and really connect to
each other on this level.
You know, we have that capacity
reminds me of the algebra teacher,
kind of asking us to look at
the problem of disconnection
or loneliness and maybe
one solution is to recall
that feeling of love that we have
for people in our lives and to maybe look
at each other through that lens.
- [Jeremy] Let's go over to Lindsay.
Lindsay, I'm gonna unmute your line,
feel free to connect with Sam.
- [Lindsay] Hi there,
can you guys hear me?
- Yeah, hi Lindsey.
- Thank you so much Sam, I
appreciate this, this is awesome.
So for me, it was also
when I was traveling
and I think there was a few of us
said we were somewhere
far, far away from home.
So I was in *** me and
(mumbles) a couple of years ago
and I was watching the sunrise
over hundreds of thousands of pagodas
and it literally just
seemed like time stopped
and the sun took forever to come up,
the transformation of the sky.
And so that was really
nice to kind of go back
and revisit that I haven't looked
at those photos in forever
but I was sitting on the
pagoda, looking at the sunrise,
I was right there back in that moment.
And I try not to focus
too much on the past,
try to focus on the present
and maybe the next day
or the next week but
this was a nice reminder
that it is okay to kind
of go back to the past
and think of those, those moments of awe,
so thank you for that so much.
- Oh, thank you.
Again, I got chills for my whole body.
I could see them as these pagodas
as you were describing them in my mind.
You know, when we listened to stories
each other's stories, we're giving gifts.
That's how I see stories
where we're really
gifting each other with
these pleasant experiences
because our brain doesn't
really know the difference
between living it, like being there again
and being here now,
the only differences are our motor cortex
which is activated when we're
actually physically moving.
But our brain, you know,
going back to the past
and really reliving some of
these moments is so good.
The researcher who I love and
I've done these workshops with
she talks about it like
a multivitamin, you know,
the benefits you're giving yourself
by recalling the past and sharing stories
and listening to stories is
medicinal in so many ways.
So yeah, I encourage you all
to really go there often.
and every time we go there,
we're reinforcing it,
so it's easier to drop in, before bed,
if you're having a hard
time falling asleep,
go to the pagodas, go to your child,
looking into their eyes,
go to the Coliseum,
wherever it is, but touch
into it because it's this pool
of nourishment and it
really, you know changes.
I think hopefully you all feel a shift,
our nervous system has settled down
and if I was just
listening to these stories
after a busy day and didn't ground myself
I wouldn't have gotten all
these wonderful sensations
of tingling and warmth and
the visions of your stories.
So we need that rest,
we need that stillness
and rejuvenation to then access
each other more intimately
and have empathy this deep,
deep embodied empathy.
So that's what I would
love you to take away
the time has flown by, but that it,
to take away looking for
the good, it's a practice,
looking around and even just
the space you're in right now
and appreciating, I have
photos of my family up here
and all these wonderful memories
but just looking for the good and finding
extraordinariness in the ordinary
especially in your students,
and maybe even try looking
at them through the eyes of a parent
or that feeling of unconditional
positive regard, even,
especially I should say
the most difficult students
who challenge us in so many ways, but yeah
also teach her some
really beautiful lessons.
So it has just been such
a pleasure to be with you
I really hope that you
feel refreshed, rejuvenated
that the tank is a little bit more full
and we can just close our
eyes for one last moment
and just connect there, how
many people on this cal?
Over 400, 600, 650
people that we can't see,
we heard some voices, but
we know they're there.
All of us educator, teaching,
learning from our students
giving of ourselves, we're
part of this community
even though we can't see
each other, we're here
to just taking a moment
to send these kind wishes
to our whole community,
can think of these beams
of light going out from
our home all the way around
the world and at least the country,
but we can include the
world community of teachers.
May we all find joy, may
we all have as many moments
of awe as possible in our lives.
May we all know we're not alone,
may we all feel connected
and safe and healthy.
(exhales)
And you've sent that out
and now just take a few breaths receiving
from the 650 people
that have sent it to you
just breathing in all the
good that's been sent your way
and letting it land in your
body, your mind, your heart.
Letting this feeling of
connection and ease, linger
and just taking it into
the rest of your evening.
Maybe the next person you make eye contact
with just sending them
kindness through your eyes
and can open our eyes and
for all the timekeepers,
it's exactly five o'clock.
So I wanna honor and respect your time
and just say thank you so
much to our whole team,
to Jeremy and Alice and Leno
for putting this all together
and all of you for coming.
It's been a pleasure and I
hope we can do this again soon.
Really genuinely.
- Thank you so much, Sam.
I just wanted to end on
this note from Michelle
which I thought was so perfect.
Michelle says thank you
for this brief respite
from the rigors of the day to day.
And we all know that
teaching has those rigors,
it was a precious gift.
Maybe you also find joy
and time that you can share
with others in this wonderful practice.
So thank you all for joining today.
Thank you, Sam, for
sharing your gifts with us
and we wish you all a wonderful spring.
- Thank you.
Bye everybody.